[Musique]
vous êtes venu accompagné ici peut-être
avec un ami un proche un parent
peut-être votre moitié
eh bien pouvons-nous commencé et ce que
je vous demande une faveur
regardez le bien regardez la bien
regardez cet être cher et demandez vous
je vois qu'il ya de l'amour
ils ont déjà compris merci
regardez donc cet être cher et posez
vous la question suivante quelle est
cette énergie qui vous unit l'un à
l'autre en quoi cette puissance qui vous
apporte du réconfort et de la confiance
pourrait vous aider à accomplir vos
rêves
cette puissance fait peur elle fait peur
car on ne la contrôle pas bien elle fait
peur car même pour un talk
ted eh bien on perd parfois ses moyens
elle fait peur aussi car elle peut faire
autant de mal que de bien
c'est même cette force qui fait peur qui
fait dire aux parents à leurs enfants
mais si toi des sentiments l'amour c'est
pour les faibles
j'ai souvent entendu ces paroles dans la
bouche des grands et j'ai donc longtemps
douté de la capacité à maîtriser mes
sentiments
j'ai donc mis de côté commence par avoir
une tête bien faite moi qui rêvais
d'amour il grande aventure discipline et
je m'emploie bac en poche mention peut
mieux faire
combien de fois j'ai entendu ce peu
mieux ferme école de commerce ou je
m'accroche
mais je trouve mon énergie et toute mon
oxygène au bureau des sports puis je met
définitivement de côté mes facultés
sentimentale lorsque j'ai accompli mon
service militaire mais j'y trouve des
nobles valeurs et j'y mets du coeur et
je deviens même officier aspirants et
c'est avec cette discipline et ce
travail de mon état d'esprit que je
viens dirigeants d'entreprises au cours
des dix prochaines années
j'évolue dans le monde de l'entreprise
et j'atteins les sommets d'une
hiérarchie bien établie les 32 ans
encore me lâche ma tête a épuisé mon
corps le fort leur date à frapper à ma
porte je n'ai plus de force plus
d'énergie chaque projet me demande à
accomplir un premier geste un premier
pas qui mais juste un coup si impossible
à réaliser
je vais voir les kinés d'ostéopathe
ils m'apprennent à écouter les
vibrations de mon corps j'écoute mon
corps je retrouve petit à petit mon
énergie et grâce à l'aide des
spécialistes et de personnes
bienveillantes
je retrouve un bel équilibre entre mon
mental et mon corps je consacre les
prochaines années à développer mes
capacités corporelles d'ailleurs je
découvre le triathlon nager pédaler
courir
j'y prends tellement goût d'ailleurs que
je mets accomplir de longues distances
et je deviens iron man
nager 4 km pédaler 180 km et courir
pendant un marathon je découvre le monde
avec cette discipline tout en continuant
à travailler à côté
non mes fonctions de direction générale
mon corps offrent eux mêmes
hamon l'état d'esprit à mon système
nerveux tout la dopamine requises pour
vivre à 100 % je suis en une énergie qui
me fait vivre à 200% même soudain en
mon coeur me lâche je n'arrive plus à
gonfler mes poumons
mon coeur est entre 2 et au rapidement
pris en charge par les urgentistes
je suis accueillie dans un accueil dans
un centre de cardio vasculaires dans les
yvelines où on me dira si le diagnostic
très vite un infarctus ma tête et mon
corps ont utilisé mon coeur je me
retrouve dans une chambre avec un une
personne qui à 50 ans de plus que moi et
cette personne a une mobilité qui est
bien plus rapide que la mienne je suis
incapable de le suivre est d'ailleurs
monté les marches d'escalier c'est un
calvaire je n'y arrive pas alors
j'écoute enfin mon coeur
j'écoute vraiment mon coeur dès que je
fais un pas je fais des pauses je médite
j'écoute mon horloge interne et je
profite aussi d'ouvrir mon coeur aux
gens qui m'entourent mes amis mes
parents ma famille et surtout laurence
laurence et me suit depuis bientôt dix
ans elle vit toute mésaventure elle
m'apporte toute son énergie toute sa
confiance et à chaque fois que je tombe
elle est là elle me relève elle me
redonne confiance et espoir et elle
m'apprend elle aussi à écouter mon coeur
alors on marche ensemble
j'apprends à marcher lentement doucement
et petit à petit je trottine et je me
remets à courir mais cette fois ci avec
elle et cette confiance cette énergie
qui revient et bien au cours des trois
prochaines années qui suivent m'amène à
retrouver un bel équilibre entre encore
ma tête et mon coeur est en 2014
sur internet il découvre une aventure
qui s'appelle aarch tout arc
vous connaissez vous explique aarch
marble arch arc arc de triomphe partir
en courant de londres pour aller jusqu'à
douvres traverser la manche à la nage et
finir de calais à paris en vélo
sans s'arrêter
mais tu es fou oui cette folie cette
course je répète 1 140 km en courant 40
km à la nage
300 km à vélo mais je me dis moi
pourquoi pas finalement j'ai développé
de sacrés compétences mentale développer
un physique à toute épreuve et
maintenant j'écoute mon coeur est un an
après je me lance laurence es tu prête à
me faire confiance pour que je réussisse
cette épreuve
oui
et là j'ai pas l'air mais ça me fait une
bombe à l'intérieur
sabu à l'intérieur vous imaginez même
pas laurence m'a donné son accréditation
son consentement pour que je fasse cette
épreuve
c'est un peu comme qu intérieure elle
dit à rocky quand elles viennent
accoucher de son fils je passe vous et
tsn rocky deux vases y gagne après la
musique tatarata dalton héros qui bat
apollo creed
bah moi ça me fait le même effet on
adriana moi ma laurence m dit oui et là
mon coeur
évidemment tout prend une dimension qui
n'a plus rien à voir avec ce que je
faisais avant
mon coeur est là c'est ma priorité et
laurence m'accompagne dans ce défi je
les accompagne aussi nous accompagnons
avec des amis la famille qui sont là
pour me soutenir ma portée toute la
confiance ce capital énergie qui va me
faire réussir cette épreuve par ou parce
que oui un an plus tard un anglo-saxon
père le record et cyril blanchard
devient le recordman de l'épreuve enduro
man
[Applaudissements]
et à ce jour le record est toujours
français mais aussi d'autres français
ont fait les preuves et d'ailleurs je
les en félicite aussi parce que quand on
disait que c'était impossible
les français l'ont fait et bien mieux
que les autres parce qu'on a une tête
bien faite aussi alors l'amour ça rend
aveugle oui ça m'a rendu aveugle et
comme j'étais aveugle
ça m'a permis à développer de nouvelles
facultés et laurence était aveugle à tel
point qu'elle m'a donné sa confiance
alors je vous propose maintenant de
fermer les yeux d'imaginer parce que je
viens de courir 140 km là je vous
embarquer dans mon aventure dans ma
traversée de la manche j'ai couru 140 km
et 6 heures après je suis dans une eau à
14 degrés il est 23 heures
il fait nuit noire la nage commence je
quitte les côtes anglaises
les méduses arrive bienvenus elle me
pique le visage y en a même une qui me
pique le coup ça brûle pas de panique
mon coach m'a dit c'est normal c'est le
sait le jeu ok jeune âge
une heure après la tempête arrive des
vagues d'un mètre cinquante
je vois là tu as ça m'arrache la gorge
c'est dur
six heures de nage la tempête se calme
mais là le froid commence à faire son
effet sur mes jambes je suis tétanisé je
suis en plein doute patrick mon meilleur
ami gay sur le bateau d'assistance
mettant tous les quarts d'heure une
perche avec laquelle je m'alimente j'ai
pas le droit touché le bas tourne donc
jeune âge tout le temps évidemment je
peux pas dormir non plus
et là j'ai très froid le soleil se lève
sur les côtes françaises que je peux
observer au loin et jeux comme la plus
grave des erreurs quand on traverse la
manche à la nage
je regarde derrière moi et là je vais
les falaises anglaise
nash forest
patrick je me donne du rythme tous les
quarts d'heure 9 heures de nage comment
savoir les côtes françaises qui approche
mais là vous imaginez bien comment
donner mon coeur mon corps et ma tête il
ya que le coeur qui guident tout ça
parce que ma tête je sais plus ce qui se
passe dans ma tête je suis le petit
baigneur dans sa baignoire qui tendent
les bras
nous voulons remonter tourner passé - là
à ce moment là je suis complètement
déconnecté 12 heures de nage je vois le
cap gris nez
hélas ce parce que je redoutais le plus
c'est la version de courant ça veut dire
quoi c'est à dire que je vais nager
encore pendant trois heures j'avais
prévu 12 heures je sais que je vais
devoir nager trois heures de plus jeune
âge j'ai les mains tétanisé les avant
bras
c'est du bois du tout bras le cou c'est
complètement brûlé avec la combinaison
ma gorge
j'arrive j'ai du mal à respirer
tellement elle est enflé par l'eau salée
14 heures extinction totale
le bateau d'assistance et à ma droite un
autre bateau apparu loin avec sur la
gauche c'est laurence laurence arrive au
revoir le bateau d'assistance chéri
j'arrête mon amour t'es pas loin et
confiance vas-y nage tu vas y arriver
elle m'a pas entendu
et bien croyez de ma tête mon corps soit
en dépend à ce moment là dans cette
fraction de seconde d'une toute petite
émotion qui va tout changer
mon corps est rempli d'une énergie je
sais pas d'où elle vient
laurence au travers de son visage de ce
regard et de ces mots m'a envoyé toute
son énergie et cet amour m'a pris
l'intérieur jeune âge et je voudrais
promet au bout de quelques minutes
j'entends des voix au loin sur les
falaises je vois mon père je vois les
amis et moi je commence à sentir le
sable sont mes mains je touche les pieds
à terre sur le sable et là je sors le
sable sans les mains c'est comme s'il
avait touché terre pour la première fois
de ma vie
vous imaginez même pas je me relève et à
d'énergie que m'envahit laurence m'a mis
dans un état de grâce et c'est à dire à
cet état de grâce
je vais le garder jusqu'à la fin en vélo
sur les 300 km qui vont l'amener jusqu'à
paris hélas à l'arc de triomphe
je lève les bras je suis un dur au mal
la suite vous la connaissez
alors je sais bien que dans votre vie
vous dites derrière cyril c'est
quelqu'un pour faire ça c'est juste
impossible incroyable sachez juste une
chose c'est que je suis né avec un
souffle au coeur je suis asthmatique de
naissance j'ai un tassement de vertèbres
dans le bas du dos et j'ai une petite
scoliose d'ailleurs le médecin m'a dit
quand j'avais 17 ans arrête le vélo et
surtout arrête de courir
[Musique]
alors comment on fait pour faire ce
genre d'épreuve
comment on fait pour accomplir ses rêves
et quand on fait pour croire à l'amour
parce que la vie d'un amoureux c'est
compliqué alors moi ma recette sur
l'enduro man a été très simple j'avais
pas de plan b
j'avais pas de plan b j'étais préparé
conditionné de tout mon être à devenir
enduro man j répéter sans arrêt dans ma
tête
ce schéma de course c'est arrivé avec
mon arrivée sur lac de triomphe avec le
drapeau bleu blanc rouge dans les mains
et le vélo au dessus de ma tête
et croyez le ce jour-là un ami je savais
même pas qu'il était photographe il me
photographier et prend le flash qui pour
le cliché qui prend c'est celui dont
j'avais rêvé
la prophétie s'est réalisée j'étais
condamné à y arriver pas de plan b est
en amour passé pareil j'ai pas de plan b
laurence et là c'est mon amour c'est ma
raison d'être c'est ma raison d'exister
et s'il n'était pas là
je n'aurais pas fait ça j'aurais pas
accomplir mon rêve j'aurais pas accompli
mes rêves de gamin quand je disais je
veux être aventuriers je vais vivre
d'amour
aujourd'hui je le vis grâce à elle alors
laurence c'est mon plan à
et elle sera aussi pour toujours mon
plan b
en amour on se donne pas à moitié
c'est binaire c zéro ou c'est 100% s'est
compliqué la vie des amoureux comme une
fois j'en ai connu mois des crises amour
et je me suis promis de ne plus jamais
aimé aujourd'hui j'y arrive et ça m'aide
à accomplir des choses extraordinaires
alors je voudrais terminer avec vous en
partageant un moment de ma vie
ce moment est arrivé a pas très
longtemps c'était le 2 octobre dernier
j'étais avec un ami on natale et
couvrent toute une nuit
ça arrive
y en a qui dorment y en a qui courent
vous voulez vous
quand laurence dors syrie le cours est
donc avec david ont fait le tour du lac
d'annecy par les sommets en course à 110
km david hill matin comme à chaque fois
on rentre à la maison on prend la
voiture
david est au volant je suis à côté je
dors et david darmon d'inattention
s'endort on percute le côté enfin c'est
ce qu'on m'a raconté puisque moi j'étais
complètement endormi et moment je me
suis réveillé c'est juste quand j'ai
senti le crash
après 100 m de tonneaux un quart d'heure
passe dans la voiture on est tous les
deux inconscients et quand je me
réveille
david et là j'ai sa tête sur mon avant
bras
il est en plein délire
mais il est vivant et moi je ne ressens
aucune chose à ce moment là un plaisir
mais absolue malgré la tragédie de cette
situation je respire david respire et
trois mois plus tard je suis là avec
vous alors si vous m'accordez encore une
minute
j'aimerais qu'on ferme les yeux à
nouveau et simplement que nous
respirions pour sentir cet air ted qui
fait d'eux tant d'amour tant de
bienveillance et que nous ressentions
tout cet amour au plus profond de nous
je souffle j'aspire
je remplis mes poumons d'amour je
remplis mes poumons de tous ces terres
qui hélas si pure entre nous c'est à
dire qu'il fait du bien qui nous rend
vivant et qui nous fait prendre
conscience de ce plaisir d'être en vie
et d'ailleurs si vous regardez près de
votre être cher et que vous la regardiez
et vous quel rêve est de vous prêts à
contrer par accomplir grâce à la
puissance de l'amour merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quand même
laurence
merci
[Applaudissements]